more daily gaming news for you steam has
just announced that they are dropping
support for Windows 7 and Windows 8. so
while most people probably won't be
affected very convenient for windows
with that Windows 10 push the post on
the Steam support website says as of
January 1st 2024 steam will officially
stop supporting the Windows 7 Windows 8
and Windows 8.1 operating systems after
that date the steam client will no
longer run on those versions of Windows
in order to continue running Steam and
any games or other products purchased
through Steam users will need to update
to a more recent version of Windows this
change is required as core features in
Steam rely on an embedded version of
Google Chrome which no longer functions
on older versions of Windows in addition
future versions of steam will require
Windows feature and security updates
only present in Windows 10 and above
goes on to say although support won't
end until 2024 we strongly encourage all
Windows 7 8 and 8.1 users to updates
sooner rather than later Microsoft ended
security updates and Technical Support
to Windows 7 in January 2020 and for
Windows 8.1 in January 2023 computers
running these operating systems when
connected to the internet are
susceptible to new malware and other
exploits which will not be patched